welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question from
marisa
who says i recently heard that yoga is
actually bad and demonic
i have never heard this before and enjoy
yoga on the occasion
for both exercise and relaxation in a
world with constant stimulation i find
it nice to relax and clear your thoughts
as you're doing yoga
there is the old saying an idol mind is
the devil's playground and is that
why yoga is bad why does something that
brings me relaxation why is it
detrimental to my soul sincerely
namaste whatever noel says is right
is probably right wow great great
sign off yes
it is i i was trying to figure out if i
could sugarcoat it or no it's just it is
bad
and it almost certainly is demonic and
you shouldn't do it
okay why because yoga is not just
stretching stretching is fine meditating
actually is fine
uh clearing your thoughts and having
stillness prayer is certainly fine
but yoga is not just that yoga is a
religious ritual it is it is
a hindu liturgy that's where it comes
from and hinduism has all sorts of
different
gods that it worships that are not the
god of christianity
okay and it has all sorts of spiritual
aspects and it's got the chanting and
the humming and the
the focusing and it it falls into a
number of
theological errors pretty dangerous ones
some of some of one of them for instance
would be monism the idea that
everything is just one right every it's
all the universe man and we're part of
the universe and we're part of the
creation and god is kind of part it's
all just the same thing
man you know we're all just going back
into that same thing
that is a very popular idea in new age
it's popular in non-theistic religions
but it's
not christian the christian idea is that
and the jewish idea and the muslim idea
is that there is god
and then god the creator makes the
creation and we are part of creation so
we have a
close relationship to god and we are
made in the image of god but we are not
all just one man we
there actually are distinct things it
also falls into the heresy
of gnosticism that if you just you know
if you just sort of think certain things
and you know certain truths that that
and you just kind of meditate on that
that you'll be able to transcend the
world and that's
very important um you know
i understand we're getting into sort of
subtle distinctions here
but that is not not a christian idea
this this gnostic idea that's associated
with uh with yoga same thing with this
sort of technical idea of yoga that if
you
put your body in certain positions this
is going to unlock certain spiritual
fruits
this technical aspect is also not not
exactly christian
um but but even just the the basic fact
that it is a liturgy from another
religion that is
rather different and contradictory
toward your religion is why
you shouldn't do it if you want to
stretch and relax i recommend pilates
and meditation
and prayer yo i need you to subscribe to
my show
not just here on youtube i appreciate
that but i need you right now before you
move on i know there's going to be more
videos
go to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play type in the michael knowles
show click that subscribe button maybe
leave a five star review if you wouldn't
mind
really really appreciate it helps us
overcome some of the shenanigans from
big tech
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]